hey you guys welcome to the movie
retrospective flying solo on this one uh
just because i had to get this recorded
and edited today to get it up for the
patrons and tom is not here because he
was out running errands so i thought
well
i better like just do this one by myself
so i can kind of get it done he didn't
love this movie anyway although to be
honest i did not love this either so
here's the weird thing
i'm not entirely sure if you guys don't
know if you're not on our patreon uh
patreon or anything like that
when i put up a poll every week and i
usually give five movies
for people to for the patrons to vote on
like which one we're gonna talk about on
the movie retrospective and i do that
for
the topics for the main um you know kind
of like shows as well
now what i will usually do when i'm
making the poll i usually like to have
like a wide range of you know like i
like to have a movie from the 70s maybe
one or two from the 80s maybe one from
the 90s maybe like a more recent one
[ __ ] like that and i always try to like
spread them out across all the streaming
services that we have so i usually have
pick one from shutter one from hulu one
from amazon or whatever
um so this one ended up in the poll and
it's called the thirsty dead from 1974
and for the [ __ ] life of me i can't
remember why i put it in the poll
what it was because when we were
watching it and thomas just like this is
like so bad it's like how did this end
up in the poll
and i was like oh it's because shutter
just added it and i thought that shutter
added it because i think that vinegar
syndrome just put out if i'm not
mistaken just put out like a new dvd or
a blu-ray of it and so i was like oh it
must been shutter but then i looked at
shutter and it's not there like the only
place i could find it was to be and i
was like i wouldn't have just picked
this at random like and put it in there
so honestly i have no idea like why it
ended up in the poll and but it won
though so i was just kind of like okay
well we're kind of stuck like talking
about it now and i okay now the thing
about it this is kind of one of those
1970s
exploitation films that came out of the
philippines
and
that sounds like pretty cool like
exploitation cinema you think there's
going to be like a lot of nudity or a
lot of gore or something like that
this movie had surprisingly
little of either i mean there is as far
as i know there is no nudity not even
boobies and honestly hardly any blood at
all this really could have used some
sleaze uh really could have used some
naked ladies really could have used some
gore
that's really like um yeah
this movie like i said it kind of sounds
cool like the concept of it and the
concept of it was actually like a pretty
good concept but it was just like
as it was boring as [ __ ] i mean to be
honest with you uh i hate to say that
but it looked pretty nice and you know
like i said it kind of had an
interesting story not an original story
uh but
it really just was it seemed like it was
85 percent like people just like walking
around in the woods it was very
very much like roger corman's early work
in that way it's like well we only have
like 20 minutes of exciting footage so
we have to like pat it out with people
just like wandering around all over the
place so that's essentially what this is
it's basically like uh kind of scantily
clad women like wandering around in the
jungle and occasionally like something
interesting will happen
and yeah it was just uh really more
boring than anything else there's just
really nothing to recommend it but since
it won in the poll and even though like
i said i don't know how it ended up in
there so i guess we're going to talk
about
so this movie was actually as i said it
came out in 1974 it was directed by a
guy named terry becker who as far as i
know didn't uh didn't direct any other
film so this was like his only one i
think as far as as far as i could
determine although a lot of the actors
in it looked real familiar especially
there's this one guy john considine and
i was like god damn it i couldn't i i
was like i know that guy i've seen him
in another movie like fairly recently
but i couldn't think what it was i think
there was a movie called the day time
ended or the day time stopped or some
[ __ ] like that that i might have seen on
mystery science theater or i might have
like watched and i think he was in that
but i went to his imdb page and like
because he does have one he was in a
[ __ ] on his stuff he was in like a bunch
of movies he was a bunch of tv but it
was nothing that i was all that familiar
with like he was in a lot of tv like in
the 70s and 80s but it wasn't anything
that i would have remembered him from so
i must have seen him from i think the
movie's called the day the time the day
time ended or something like that i
think i remembered him from that because
i was like it was something that i saw
recently and there were actually a
couple women in this that were in that
were like soap opera actresses and stuff
like that
so here the premise of the movie is that
it's set in manila at least the first
part of it and the whole thing is that
well women are being kidnapped off the
streets of manila and taken god knows
where you know what i mean most people
and they kind of like
you know build it up at the beginning
where oh they're being kidnapped and
like sold into white slavery or sold
into prostitution or whatever the hell
interestingly too i'm not sure about the
blu-ray release but as far as i know
like i saw like some uh some screenshots
of like the old vhs cover and the vhs
cover has like a tagline on it that says
a surgical nightmare and i'm actually
not
i don't i don't know what the [ __ ] that
has there is no surgical nothing like in
the movie so i don't know like why
that's even on there like whoever came
up with that tag line just like didn't
even watch the movie clearly so i just
thought i would mention that so we start
at the beginning with this woman named
claire who i think is again one of those
uh soap opera actresses that i was uh
talking about her name is judith
mcconnell the act the actor
and she looks a little bit she kind of
reminded me she doesn't really look like
her but i like her whole like kind of
gestalt or her vibe or whatever was
giving me a very ginger from gilligan's
island kind of thing
so she's dancing in a cage in a
nightclub in manila
and even though it's ostensibly a strip
club she's just wearing like a sparkly
bikini or whatever and she just like
shimmies around in this like you know
five dollar cage that's like made of
plastic or whatever and everybody's
hooting and hollering but i'm like she's
not even naked i don't know why
everybody's getting so excited but
whatever
uh so yeah so she's actually not the
main character although i kind of wish
she would would have been because i
think the best thing about the movie is
just how
bizarre like all of her um reactions are
to anything to everything that happened
to this movie which i'll get into in a
little bit now who ends up being the
actual main character of this is a woman
named laura and it's interesting because
i don't think they mentioned this in the
movie but i was like the outfit she was
wearing i'm like she looks like uh you
know an air hostess or whatever like a
like a stewardess as they would have
called it back then and i but i don't
think they mentioned that in the movie
but actually when i looked up and i was
researching about the movie that's
that's what she's supposed to be so i
was like okay well i guess they did the
costuming good on that
so um she has like this hair that really
needs some deep conditioning uh she
really desperately needs some vo5 on
that but you know what i mean i'm not
i'm not gonna get too um get too wrapped
up in that so there's a scene of her and
she has uh this boyfriend francisco who
he wants to marry her i guess and she
doesn't really want to get married and
it's supposed to be like all you know
because she's just about to get
kidnapped spoiler alert so it's supposed
to be all [ __ ] all poignant and
everything like that so i mean it's not
but you know so yeah so they they kind
of like leave and she's kind of like oh
i can't get married or whatever and then
she he's wearing like this really really
loud like checked coat um you know so of
course i had to make some like
some comments about that but she goes
behind this door into wherever and she
immediately gets kidnapped by these
dudes who they just look like monks
really they look like they have like
kind of they're just these brown robes
that look kind of like brand new and so
they kind of snatch her and like take
her away
so as they take her away they end up in
the jungle someplace and she meets up
with claire who's also been kidnapped
and then there's this other woman named
bonnie who's like an asian woman and
then there's like another blonde chick
who's
younger i guess i think she's like
supposed to be a teenager but i think
she looks like she's in her 20s but she
looks like a little bit younger than the
other two
so what ends up happening they're kind
of like okay well we're being sold into
prostitution they're assuming now claire
the chick that was dancing at the in the
cage at the beginning she is totally
fine with this and she's just kind of
like okay awesome you know if you can
she says something like if you can make
money like without even leaving your
bedroom then
more is the better you know what i mean
and i don't know it's just very very
weird and like even when like the
kidnappers like one of them like picks
her up because she like you know twists
her ankle or some [ __ ] like that she's
just like oh hey you big hunk of man you
don't mean it i'm just kind of like uh
all right this is a very very strange
reaction that she's having she's like oh
i'm gonna go be a white slave how
exciting you know
it's like it's so [ __ ] crazy and like
i said i kind of wish that she had sort
of been the main character they should
have been
you know i mean she's a main character
but she's not like the main character
you know what i'm saying but it's just
like her
just bizarre reactions to everything
were like a highlight of the movie
pretty much the only one so after an
interminable amount of time where
they're walking through the jungle
they end up at this
sort of like
it's like a cave like it's a bunch of
tunnels and stuff like that it looks
this movie looks exactly like an episode
of the original star trek that's exactly
what the phrase i don't know where they
shot this um i don't know if it's some
kind of backlot someplace uh it said it
was shot in the philippines but so i
don't know where this is it looked like
the same studio sets that they would use
like if you know the crew of the
enterprise were off on some planet
somewhere and like all these
you know space hippies like lived in a
syria like in a series of games it looks
exactly like that so i'm not entirely
sure where this is there's not a great
deal of information about this movie out
there
so uh so yeah so they go to this like
cave
these cave people and they all kind of
look like they're all kind of like young
and hot and they wear kind of like
logan's runny kind of
uh logan's ronnie they look like logan's
logan's run-esque kind of uh outfits
that are kind of like silky little short
skirts and everything
and what this is like the guy that plays
um
that john considine the character he
plays
is named baru
and he has this crazy
like baby blue romper type situation
with all these big medallions and one
version of it has this collar that's
just like all the way up here like up
just it's it's astounding i mean it's
astounding
so this
society i guess because i was like okay
well now they're finally here it's like
these must be the vampires
because i was assuming thirsty dead that
sounds like vampires right
they're not exactly vampires they do
drink blood
but they're not undead though so the
whole thing about it is that every now
and then they'll kind of like go
someplace and kidnap a bunch of ladies
and then the weird thing though is that
when they like they drink their blood
but they don't kill them like they just
put them all in these slabs it's very
efficient like this system they have um
you know kind of worked out but they
have like this big sort of courtyard and
it has like all these slabs on it and
then they lay all the victims and then
they just kind of like stab their necks
and they drain some blood out and in a
bowl and then they have these like magic
leaves or something that will heal it
immediately so i'm just like oh okay
well
whatever um so i was just kind of like
so you're not even killing them it's
like so they didn't really seem like
much of a threat but then you find out
later on
that
yeah it might seem like oh we're just
draining some blood out of you and then
we're healing it up so you know no harm
no foul but it turns out that
after they do that
to the victims for a little bit like so
they age really quickly the victims and
then they like kind of throw them in
this ooblee type or like a little cell
and they're also they're all these like
crazy old ladies with like crazy gray
hair everywhere and they'll say
something like oh yeah that one she's 28
you know she was here for five years so
it's like supposedly ages you really
quickly
but all of the people in the logan's run
outfits are
like i said they're not exactly vampires
because they're not undead like they
didn't come back from the dead but they
are
immortal or they're really really long
live so that's kind of why you know
kidnap these people and bring them there
and drink their blood and that makes
them immortal and they don't get sick
and there's all this other kind of stuff
so they have this new batch of ladies
there and like i said claire the chick
from the beginning the ginger woman
she's just sitting there going kind of
like hey you know i got a nice bed and
they're giving us food it's like
whatever and she's just totally fine
with it even though they totally got
kidnapped but i was like uh okay well
wait wait a look on the bright side i
guess
she's just like and she kind of gets mad
like when they try to escape it's like
what no i'm having a good time it's like
it's it's crazy
so yeah so it turns out though that the
one uh the woman that needs conditioner
laura
the stewardess she looks like
some woman that beru the guy with the
crazy baby blue big collar that he
painted a long time ago like he had a
vision of her so she's kind of like the
chosen one type person it's like oh
we've been waiting for you you're gonna
be like our newest edition because
they're very like elitist um you know
what i mean they're kind of like well
everything we only worship beauty and so
that's why they let like the you know
the victims that they drain the blood
out of they're just kind of like oh well
they're old bats now they don't kill
them but they kind of just throw them in
a thing like like they're a bunch of
like animals or whatever um because
they're not pretty anymore um but
apparently every now and then like
they'll allow somebody to join their
exalted ranks or whatever so because
beru had
a
vision of this woman that he painted um
that she's supposedly you know destined
to come there and be part of it
but laura is like not having it she's
like bro i mean one you guys kidnapped
me um two like i'm here with these other
three women who are now my friends
because you know we bonded over this
whole being kidnapped situation and
she's like i'm not letting you guys just
drain all of their blood
sit and you know make them age
prematurely and die
uh just so i can live forever and hang
out with you knobs because
what the [ __ ] and it's funny because
they all seem like really like he's like
well why wouldn't you want to do that
you know what i mean like it seems like
his mind is blown by the fact that she
wouldn't want to do it she's like but
they aren't your friends like you just
met that she's like dude i mean we've
been kidnapped together we've been in
the same cell blah blah
she's like i'm not gonna [ __ ] them over
so it comes to a point where you know
she's trying to escape like i said
claire's like i mean we have to and
she's like yes claire we have to escape
okay i know you like this whole
kidnapping and being a white slave
situation and having your blood drained
and all this other kind of stuff but
it's not good and probably we should go
back to our regular lives so
they do try to escape like one of the
older ladies whose name is well she's
not older but she looks older she's only
28 they said her name is eva and she
like takes pity on them and she kind of
helps them escape
and
i mean the escape is like super easy and
i mean the guys do come after them when
they figure out that they've gotten out
but
you know then it turns out that beru
kind of flips and he's fallen in love
with laura blah blah blah and so he
actually kind of helps them knowing that
as soon as he goes outside of the bounds
of whatever this it's essentially like a
shangri-la type story like as soon as he
goes outside of the bounds of that he's
gonna age really quickly and die so he
actually sacrifices himself to like to
help them escape and they get back to
civilization except for claire who
actually ends up before they even get
out of the cave system she ends up like
falling in a pit and dying so
you know but she didn't want to leave
anyway so i guess that was a win-win for
everybody because uh she didn't leave
she ended up in the in the rat pit with
all the other skeletons and [ __ ] like
that so uh so as i mentioned
this movie
i don't really remember it must maybe it
was on shutter for like a week or two
and then it disappeared i do know that
vinegar syndrome put out i think a
blu-ray of it recently i don't know if
it's just on its own or if it's like a
double feature because i have seen it
like as a double feature with um some
other vampire movie but like i said
don't go into this thinking it's a
vampire movie because it's not really
these people at the shangri-la place are
not
vampires in the sense they're vampires
in the sense that they drink blood and
that makes them live longer or it makes
them immortal you know for all intents
and purposes but they're not undead and
they don't have like magical powers
really they're just kind of like living
out in these caves like at this little
you know in this little place
and so
the thing about it too is that when i
say something like and i've seen some
other kind of like exploitation
films that came out from this era like
from the philippines and usually the
appeal of watching them is they're real
sleazy or you know they're very gory
like there's a lot of like [ __ ] up
gore or you know a lot of nudity or
whatever and this one doesn't have any
of that like seriously the only time you
see blood is one time that it's like
they cut one of their necks and like a
little trickle comes out and they put it
in a bowl and then there's like one very
brief scene toward the end when there's
like a kind of a big melee with the um
with the older ladies that are in the
cell
um you know they kind of like tear
somebody's face and it's kind of like a
little bit bloody there but that's
literally it there that's all the gore
there is there is zero nudity um the
women run around in
i mean laura the main one she kind of
has like this hot pink like toga
situation um that's very like diaphanous
and uh and the other ladies just have
these kind of like
brown
bikini things it's like kind of like a
loin cloth and there's kind of like a
bra thing that's like tied like across
their boobs or whatever so you don't
really get to see any nudity like i said
i don't really care about that but i'm
just saying it's kind of like that's
what people watch these movies for and
this is very very
tame so i don't really see
i don't really know who i would
recommend this to to be honest with you
because it's like it doesn't have like
the sleaze factor that you would look
for in a movie like this you know if you
wanted to follow the story that would be
fine but the story's not really all that
original and it's not really all that
compelling um you know other than a
couple of funny things that happen i
forgot to mention too like as far as
funny things is that this
society whatever you want to call them
like all these people that live in the
caves
they worship this
god i guess
who is like a severed head but he's
inside like a big block of like red it
looks like jello to be honest with you
it looks like it's like a square big
cube of jell-o mold and there's like a
head in there and it talks sometimes
like they can ask it quests like they're
like oh whatever it's called and um and
it talks and opens its eyes and whatnot
so i forgot to mention that too so
that's like kind of crazy like i said
it's nicely shot like it's very colorful
like um you know i liked that the sets
and the costumes kind of very much
reminded me of
60s star trek which was kind of cool but
it's
to be honest i think that's also it's
its biggest weakness is that
it's basically like a really really
boring
episode of star trek without any of the
characters that you like you know what i
mean that's essentially what it is i
mean i've seen episodes of star trek
that had more gore and like more sex
appeal than this um so i think that's
kind of like the main thing about this
movie is that it's just really really
dull i mean most of it is just like
walking around
in the jungle
uh whining and
that's it and then every now and then
claire will make like a funny comment
about how she's so into like
she's very excited about her whole like
career in white slavery or whatever um
and that's like pretty much it so
as i said um
sorry it's just me on this one but
because i i kind of wanted like some
back and forth with tom on this one
because he watched it too but he like
checked out pretty early he's like this
is really bad it's like it's so boring
and i was like yeah this is pretty
boring like i was trying to like make
jokes about it like because there is
some funny [ __ ] going on in it but
overall it's just really not worth
watching at all there's just
there's just nothing really to recommend
it it's just like very unless you want
it for like to put you to sleep because
it probably would do that but like i
said it looks like it was competently
shot it doesn't look like it was
all that cheap um the acting is fine
actually it's not really all that
terrible um and i've recognized a lot of
the actors in it so it's not like a
bunch of nobodies or anything like that
but there just isn't anything all that
interesting about it so i mean it's on
2b for free if you want to watch it and
see what i'm talking about i'm sure you
probably have better things to do with
your time
unless you're like really really curious
but yeah so that will do it for this
movie retrospective and i will see you
guys on the next one bye
you